to linger on the the trade-offs the
complicated trade-offs with all this
uh what's your take on work-life balance
in uh in a in a company that's trying to
do
big things
I think that you have to have
some very very strict boundaries
but otherwise I think balance is kind of
dumb
it will make you Limited
I think you need to immerse yourself in
the problem
but you need to Define that immersion
with boundaries so if you you know if
you ask me like you know what does like
my process look like
it's monotonous and regimented but it's
all the time except when it's not and
that's also monotonous and regimented
um
and I think that makes me very good at
my craft
because it gives me what I need
to stay connected to the problem without
feeling resentful about the problem
which part the monotonous all in nature
of it or the the when you say hard
boundaries essentially
go all out until you stop and you don't
stop often I'm in a little bit of a
quandary right now
because I'm trying to redefine my goals
and you're catching me in a moment where
I have even in these last
few years of evolution I think I've made
some good progress
but in one very specific way I'm still
very reptilian
and I'm trying to let go which was
exactly if you can you know in my
business it really gets reduced to what
is your annual rate of compounding
that's my demarcation you know
Steph Curry and LeBron James Michael
Jordan it's how many points did you
average not just in a season
but over your career
you know and in their case to really be
the greatest of all time
its points rebounds assists steals
there's all kinds of measures
to be you know in that Pantheon of being
really really good at your craft
um and in my business it's very
reductive it's how I love you compounded
and if you look at all the heroes that I
have put on a pedestal in my mind
um
they've compounded you know at above 30
percent for a very long time
as have I
but now I feel like I really need to let
go because I think I know how to do the
basics of my job
and if I had to summarize like an
investing challenge or investing I think
really it's you know when you first
start out investing you're a momentum
person you saw it in GameStop just a
bunch of people aping each other
and then it goes from momentum
to you start to think about cash flows
you know how much profit is this person
going to make whatever so that's like
the evolution you know this is the this
is the basic thing to this is a
reasonably sophisticated way then a much
smaller group of people think about it
in terms of macro geopolitics
but then a very finite few cracked this
special code which is there's a
philosophy and it's the philosophy that
creates the system
and I'm scratching at that furiously but
I cannot break through and I haven't
broken through and I know that in order
to break through I gotta let go
so this is the journey that I'm in as in
my in my professional life
so it is an all-consuming thing but I'm
always home for dinner
you know we have very prescribed moments
where we take vacation the weekends you
know like if I I can tell you about my
week if you're curious but it's like I
would love I would love to know your
week it's since it's regimented uh
uh monotonous I woke up I wake up at 6
45
um
get the kids go downstairs we all have
some form of you know not super healthy
breakfast I make a latte I've become in
and and the latte is like I have a
machine I measure the beans you know I
make sure that the timer is such where I
have to pull it for a certain specific
ratio you know just so you know 20 grams
I gotta pull 30 grams with the water and
I got you know I gotta do it 30 seconds
Etc so your uh coffee snob it helps me
stay in rhythm sure
um before I used to have another machine
I just pushed a button yeah but then I
would push the button religiously in the
exact same way you know what I mean okay
casket actually on uh on that topic
you know the morning with kids can be
pretty stressful thing are you able to
find sort of happiness is that also that
morning is a source of Happiness it's
great my kids are lovely their maniacs
um
I just see
you know and maybe I don't I've never
asked rebrook this but I'll just put my
words I see all of the things in moments
where
there was no compassion given to me and
so I just give him a ton of love and
compassion I have an infinite patience
for my children not for other kids yes
of course but for a lot of kids so
anyway so we have a breakfast thing
um
and then I go upstairs
um and I go I change and I and I work
out from eight to nine
and that's like the first 15 minutes I
walk up on a steep incline you know uh
12 to 14 you know three and a half to
four miles per hour
walk
and then you know Monday's a push day
Tuesdays
front of the legs Wednesdays pull
Thursdays back of the legs
um eight to nine
Monday I always start I talk to my
therapist from nine to ten so as soon as
I finish working out I get on the phone
and I talk to him
and it helps me lock in for the for the
for the week
and I and I and I'm just talking about
the past
um and it's just helping me the recent
past usually sometimes the recent past
but usually it's about the past past
something that I remember when I was a
kid
because that's the work about just
loosening those knots you know so I put
in that hour of work
um respect that hour
but then I'm in the office and then it's
like you know I go until
12 15 12 30.
go home
have lunch
like a proper like go home sit down have
lunch with Nat talk she leaves for work
can we talk how are we doing you know
just check in our youngest daughter will
be there because she's one
and she's making a mess
and then I'll have another coffee
that's it my limit for the day oh no
more caffeine that's it and then uh I go
back to the office and I'll be there
until six seven sometimes
and I do that Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Monday Tuesday Thursday Friday
I'm allowed to have meetings Wednesday
nothing it's all reading must be unless
it's a complete emergency it has to be
uh kind of a full reading and reading is
a bunch of blogs uh YouTube videos so
I'm not trying not to do any talking no
talking it's like being in silence being
present thinking about things by the way
how do you take notes give us a sketch I
have a pad and I write stuff down
sometimes I go to my phone I'm a little
all over the place sometimes I do Google
Docs I don't have it this is one thing I
need to get better at actually
but typically what happens is I actually
do a lot of thinking in my mind and I'm
sort of filing a lot of stuff away and
then it all spills out and then I have
to write
and then that gives me a body of work
that I can evaluate and think about and
then I usually put it away
um and a lot of the time it goes nowhere
but every now and then I come back to it
and it just unlocks two or three things
and I have a sense of how else I'm
thinking about things
um and then Friday at the end of the day
uh Nat and I talk to a couple's
therapists
um and that's about checking out
properly
so it's like okay
now it's like focusing the weekend is
family
being present being aware you know and
if there's email obviously if I have to
do meetings from time to time no problem
um but there's boundaries checking out
properly
um oh man that is so powerful just like
yeah officially transitioning yeah
so these are these are really important
boundaries so that I can be immersed and
what that means is like look on a
Saturday afternoon you know on a random
day she'll be like where's your mouth
and I'll be up in my room and I've found
a podcast talking about like um uh decis
which is like ductal cancer in situ
because I've been fascinated about
breast cancer surgeries for a while and
uh learning about that and she's like
what are you doing I'm like I'm
listening to podcasts about decis and
she's like what's that like you know
ductal cancer in C2
she's like okay
and so you know I so I have time to
continue to just constantly learning
learning putting stuff in my memory
banks to organize into something and
that's like a that's a week
but then in these fixed moments of time
phone down everything down we go on
vacation you know
we go on a boat we go to whatever where
it's just us and the kids
is there a structure when you're at work
is there instructed to your day in terms
of meetings in terms of suicidal
Wednesday
you know because you're have you keep
meetings to less than 30 minutes
have to
and you know oftentimes meetings can be
as short as like 10 or 15 minutes
because then I'm just like okay
because I'm trying to reinforce that
it's very rare that we all have
something really important to say
and so the ritual that is becomes really
valuable to get scale
is not the ritual of meetings but the
ritual of respecting the collective time
of the unit
and so it's like you know what folks I'm
going to assume that you guys are also
tackling really important projects you
also want to have good boundaries in
this immersion go back to your kids and
have dinner with them every night it's
not just for me it's for you so how
about this why don't you go and do your
work this painting didn't need to be 30
minutes it could be five and the rest of
the time is yours and and it's weird
because when people join that system at
Social Capital they just
it's like face time and it's like let me
make sure and let me talk a lot so I
can't say anything I respect the person
that says nothing for two years and the
first thing that they say is not obvious
that person is immensely more valuable
than the person that tries to talk all
the time